my big fear is not that the
conservatives in the next election
although I hope that they don't
it's that the labor wins the next
election
they don't do anything about orphan
equality things continue to get worse
and then people start feeling like we
need something more extreme you know
we need something more extreme and then
we you know what is happening now in
terms of the rapid decrease in living
standards the rapid increase inequality
very similar to the 1920s and 1930s you
know look what happened then
you know you're a fell into fascism
we had the second world war we had the
Holocaust where the Nazis you know I'm
not saying look I'm not saying these
things will happen again you know and I
pray to God that these things do not
happen again but if you
people will vote for something sensible
three times four times five times maybe
six times and if every single time their
life gets worse and worse and worse
eventually they'll vote for something
insane and and you will you can
understand why they would do that right
so